Hi, Vsauce. Michael here.
You can practice speaking backwards, so when your words are reversed
their intelligible. But here's something
else that is weird.
The digits in the speed of light are
exactly the same
as the latitude of the Great Pyramid of Giza.
And, as the anagram genius has revealed, all the world's
a stage but if you rearrange the letters
in the meaning of life
it becomes be engine of a film
or, more pessimistically, the fine game of nil.
What does all of this mean?
Are these just coincidences?
Or are greater powers at work?
Why is it so easy for us to find
hidden messages? Why can a mere
coincidence give us chills
and why is it so fun?
When you reverse Neil Armstrong saying 'small step for man'
you can hear what sounds like man will
space walk
Lee Harvey Oswald assassinated
President John F Kennedy
and this interview he defends the Fair
Play for Cuba committee
of which he was a member.
Now listen to what it
sounds like when we reverse him saying
'and the Fair Play for Cuba'.
is that a coincidence or a subconscious
confession hidden within his own words?
It's a coincidence.
For crying out loud, if anybody says 'and
the Fair Play for Cuba',
and then reverses it, it sounds the same.
This app, by the way, is called
Virtual Recorder.
It's a really easy way to quickly reverse
your own speech.
Matthew Hutson in 'The 7 Laws of Magical Thinking' points out that if you record
yourself saying
and then reverse it
it sounds a bit like happy birthday to
you
Kind of.
If a word can be spelt the
same forward
and backward, it's a palindrome.
But if a word or phrase
sounds the same, whether spoken forward
or rewound,
it is a phonetic palindrome.
For example,
say yes. Reversed
Pretty cool. But  check out this poem by
Karsten Johansson
By the way, some people can speak in
reverse on the fly
It is really cool to see them in action.
Watch Guy's lean back
after this video. It's linked down in the
description and it's full of pretty cool coincidence videos.
Apophenia is the perception of
connections or patterns
in information.
One type of Apophenia is Pareidolia -
the scene or hearing of things that
weren't meant to be there.
For instance, hearing your name being
called or your phone ringing
in the sound of running water, or
hearing English words
in a non-English song or seeing faces
that weren't purposely placed there. Our
brains are good at this kind of work,
probably because being hyper
attentive to patterns and faces
can save your life. If there's ambiguity
as to whether that
thing hiding in the shadows is a threat, or just a shadow,
it's advantageous to air on the side
of threat. Organisms with a healthy sense of Apophenia
live longer, long enough to have kids and
raise them
and naturally become the norm. We connect
with
faces so well Hutson relates a story of
a friend who draws
faces on things she doesn't wanna lose,
like her bags.
She says the faces make her less likely to
forget about them.
If you like it, you should have put a
ring on it, if you like not losing it,
you should have drawn a face on it.
We are so good at
teasing out patterns and faces from
random noise
actual random sequences don't always
feel random to us.
Originally, Apple's iTunes shuffle feature generated
complaints from users.
They said that similar songs, or songs
from the same artist,
appeared in a string, which, of course, is
to be expected
from randomness but it didn't feel
random enough.
So Apple introduced a smart shuffle
that avoided totally random sequences
that nonetheless
didn't seem random to our pattern
loving brains.
As Steve Jobs explained, "we're making it
less random
to make it feel more random".
Our impressive ability to imagine
patterns also expresses itself when it
comes to connecting songs
and moving images. This dancing
Spider-Man animation will
famously sync up with any music you play.
Try it. What kind of black magic is going on
here?
Well, as it turns out, most of it is in
our heads.
Radiolab reported that Michigan
State University explains that the major movements
of dancing animations like this one, or this one,
move at typical song tempos but also
contain, like most
dance, various other different related rhythms of movement allowing them to seemingly
fit many different tempos.
Selection bias helps a lot too.
We fall prey to this when we reject all the times the animation
doesn't really sync up, focusing instead
on the more surprising times
when it does.
The bizarre pyramid coincidence mentioned earlier
is a lot less bizarre when you consider
the fact that we got to control where
we placed the decimal point,
and that a number of degrees this precise
isn't necessary to locate the pyramid.
By the fourth decimal we're only talking
about a matter of a few meters,
so it's easy to make the rest fit the
speed of light exactly
and have still picked a point on the pyramid.
Confirmation bias also comes into play here.
If you really want two things to sync up,
they will.
We often look for evidence that supports
what we already believe,
while marginalising things against it.
As Marshall McLuhan said "I wouldn't
have seen it, if I hadn't believed it".
These biases also help explain
the seemingly mind-blowing coincidence that
famous movies and famous albums can line up.
One the most popular states that if you
start playing Pink Floyd's Dark Side of the Moon
at the same time as The Wizard of Oz,
they will eerily
line up. Entire communities have sprouted
around the syncing
of movies and albums. Some of my
favorites are the Yellow Submarine soundtrack
and the Little Mermaid, Lorde's Pure Heroine and Twilight Saga - Breaking Dawn 2,
and the end of 2001: A Space Odyssey
with Pink Floyd's Echoes.
There are conspiracies
that these were somehow secretly planned, though in reality
they're just accidental music videos. The
product of selection bias,
confirmation bias and
the law of near enough.
A behaviour of our pattern sensitive
minds.
Two things don't have to line up exactly, or literally,
for us to see a connection. This is why
vague predictions
are a great way to look psychic. These
are also actually
unsurprising when you consider the fact
that the number of narrative
paces and rhythms we enjoy, and
typically use,
are much smaller than the number possible.
In 'The Improbability Principal', David J
Hand calls this
"the probability lever".
What may be rare
on average, or when considering all
possible scenarios,
can be less rare for specific scenarios,
even if they are only marginally
different. Getting struck by lightning
is a proverbially unlikely event, but
Walter Summerford
wasn't just struck by lightning once
during his life,
he was struck three times. It never
killed him but four years after his
death
his gravestone was also struck by
lightning.
What are the chances? I mean, clearly
Summerford was some sort of
robot built out of lightning rods or had somehow angered Zeus,
right?
Probably not. You see, while for the
average person
the chance have been struck by lightning
is quite low, for an avid outdoor
sportsman like Summerford,
it's not as low.
The law of truly large numbers
also comes into play here.
With lightning striking Earth forty to
fifty times a second, billions of people
for it to strike and
thousand of years of recorded history, it's
actually not surprising at all
that at least once a story like Summerford's
would have happened.
Given the truly large number of people
who visit Disney World every day, and the fact that they take photos and lots of them,
it's actually not surprising at all that
at least one so far,
a story like Alex and Donna Voutsinas' has happened.
While sorting through old photos before
their wedding, Alex and Donna found a photo
of Donna
at Disney World, fourteen years before
the couple met.
But then Alex noticed something. He too had visited Disney World as a child, and there,
in the background, was his father pushing
him in a stroller.
Sometimes coincidences can be tragic.
In 1864, Abraham Lincoln's son,
Robert Lincoln, was saved from
serious injury - or possibly even
death - when a stranger grabbed him by the shirt collar
moments before he plunged on the train
tracks below.
That stranger turned out to be Edwin
Booth, one of the most famous
Shakespearean actors of the time. So famous in fact Robert recognized him
and had a letter sent thanking him
for saving his life. Less than a year later
Edwin Booth's brother, John Wilkes Booth,
undid the favor by
assassinating Abraham Lincoln.
Strange as they seem at first,
math says that given enough time and
psychology says that given enough interest
in finding them,
coincidences and connections will be found,
even unlikely ones. The coincidences between
Abraham Lincoln and John F Kennedy are famous.
Both were elected to the presidency in
the year ending with sixty.
Lincoln was shot at Ford's Theatre,
Kennedy was shot in a 1961 Lincoln
Continental four-door convertible,
made by Ford.
Both presidents' last names have seven letters
and both assassins had 15 letters in
their names.
The list goes on, as it should.
If you look long enough, you can find
coincidences between any two people or
things or events.
They may seem strange at first but tend to
wind up being in the end
pretty expected. For just one example,
name length isn't that wildly variable.
Seven-letter names are pretty common.
Lincoln,
Kennedy. Michael. Stevens
In the famous spooky presidential
coincidences contest,
held by the Skeptical Inquirer in 1992,
one contestant alone
found similar lists of crazy
coincidences
between 21 pairs of former presidents.
Given the vast amount of details in any one
of our lives,
it's pretty easy. This court can be
exploited to almost comedic heights
when it comes to over-analysing.
Of course, hidden messages and signs are often intentionally included in media
for fun, or to reward attentive viewers.
But unintentional, extraordinary things
happen all the time. It's not really that extraordinary.
There's a famous calculation
that is known as Littlewood's law. Given
the number of hours
we are awake every day, and
assuming an event only takes about a second to occur,
if you calculate the odds of something happening to you are only one in a million.
Well, you should expect that thing to
happen to you about once every 35 days.
David J Hand took this even further with seven billion people on Earth
the chance that an event with a
one in a million probability of happening
to each of us won't happen today is
in 10 to 3040. As Persi Diaconis put it,
the truly unusual day would be a day
where
nothing unusual happens.
And as always,
thanks for watching.
You may have noticed a lot of YouTube
channels making videos about learning this week.
Well, that is not a coincidence. It is
school of YouTube week.
Many people are going back
to school or college right now
but across the world millions of children won't be
either because they work to
support their families
or live without a home. Or in areas
where there is conflict.
They may experience overcrowding at school or a lack of teaching
and school supplies. But luckily, we can help.
Donations to Comic Relief's School of
YouTube campaign
can help disadvantaged young people all
around the world
get an education. It doesn't take much to
change a life.
You can learn more in the description below or donate right now.
And as always, thanks for helping and thanks for learning.